you guys ever seen like boyhood or that
movie
uh
what's up that sounds so familiar that's
that was a movie that like took 15 years
to make because they basically it
basically is the story of this kid and
um and how they did it is that they
filmed
every year for 15 years i think
clips that's pretty cool yeah
yeah so they
yeah do you remember that i think
did it win an oscar
you'd [ __ ] hope so yeah after 15
years yeah it was talked about a lot was
it boyhood i can't remember if that was
there was a movie like that they did
yeah now you can just go on youtube and
watch those family channels just raise
their kids
[Laughter]
yeah who needs that now the
groundbreaking thing has now been turned
into ad revenue so now now a compelling
piece of media he's just filmed farmed
on youtube yeah
why why condense it into a
feature-length film when you can make
multiples so much more ad revenue if
you're doing you know day by day uploads
you know my kids [ __ ] himself vlog you
know like episode 4
700.
if you don't see those they're like the
the kid gets called up by the principal
and they film it they're like film
picking the kid up from school after
he's been like kicked out
it's insane no this [ __ ] is insane
family vlog channels are so weird to me
it's the most scariest part of the
internet for me that's what scares me i
i can't imagine
it scares me because i can't imagine i
mean it's the complete opposite of like
a healthy environment to raise children
in right because i know it's awful like
imagine imagine you're a kid and you're
just like grown up just thinking that
everything you're gonna do is gonna be
filmed and you have to like
permanently be on entertaining mode
right we're only years away from like
the first influencer who was raised
in an influencer
like house yeah you know what i mean i
mean they're probably already born yeah
as in like what i'm saying is probably
there must be one of those kids on one
of those family channels he's gonna be
like the first big like youtuber or
something where his whole entire life
has been documented yeah willingly awful
awful just not black mirror [ __ ] right
there yeah really literally just truman
is showroom
terrifying stuff the kid is raised not
not not on his uh what he should be
taught in school but how to use google
analytics and google trends
what a terrifying thought
what
terrifying awful it's so scary what did
you want to say ashley what do you want
to know about boywood it won how long
did it like take to make
2002 to
so so 11 years 11 years so i i know it
got like cancelled it almost got
canceled because the cast members just
wanted to stop doing it like imagine
being tied to a project for like 11
years and having to do this one thing
every year even though you never know if
the film is going to be even be finished
and released i mean that's yeah that's
because like 11 years it's literally you
know a kid just starting school to
almost graduating school yeah that's a
long time yeah especially for a kid yeah
that is the entire point of the movie
because you literally get to see this
kid grow up oh my god and a lot of it
like wasn't scripted a lot of it i i
might be talking my ass but like i know
like they had i think i had the rough
plan but because they didn't know what
would happen in life
sometimes i had to change the script
every year depending on depending on
what happens so i mean i highly
recommend you guys watch it it's a
[ __ ] amazing film sounds good um
yeah because like it's it's rare to see
a project that lasts for a long time and
you get to see the end of that project
and i think some some things like attack
on titan is such a rarity that we should
cherish it whenever we do get to see
something like this i i guess i had a
normie anime weekend because i also
watched the new season of demon slow ah
oh yeah how how is that i've been
getting started it's so good it's crazy
man so i watched the movie right before
i watched the new season yeah and the
animation in the season was like way
better than the movie really
i'm not kidding really yeah i i was
watching the train arc thinking waiting
for some like insane you know movie
budget animation kicking and i was like
oh it's not really that much different
from the episode i would say the last
fight scene was pretty crazy though it
was pretty the last fight scene was
nothing like that they didn't already do
in like the tv show i guess yeah the bar
of quality was pretty high i don't know
i don't know who's in charge of the
animation there but holy [ __ ] how did
they even step it up more like there was
a
man discovers you photography
no i know it was just like how do they
keep doing this how do they keep getting
away with it like it's like mapper as
well like every year they just step it
up somehow genuinely the new season of
demon slayer is really good and i hate
to be that normy guy who's like yo i
just heard this amazing animation but
like it's it's it's good it's really
good yeah really [ __ ] good i've been
meaning to start it just because i did
actually finally get around to watching
you know after all those years
and i really enjoyed it yeah so
i want to watch it really i haven't seen
the new season demonstrate and it's one
of those shows where i'm just like i'll
watch it when i feel like watching anime
with no pressure to like make a [ __ ]
video about it like that you're not yeah
because like to me like attack on titan
and demon slay i'm like everyone already
knows these shows i don't need to make
another video about them yet
i think i've made like [ __ ] four
videos i'm talking about attack on titan
is still a masterpiece
i can't form an opinion unless giger
also agrees with it yeah
uh on his video about it you know i if
he says it's a masterpiece it's a
masterpiece i need that strong nine to a
light 10 you know
it's like okay there we go
i mean would you say demon slayer like
would you say it's as good as the first
season or is it like even better
when did the last season come out how
many years ago is that now
26 2019
right before we moved to japan right
was it 2019 i thought it was a before
that because i feel like i don't know if
i'm just like i'm forgetting but i feel
like it's better than the first season
oh yeah i feel like i've been enjoying
it a lot more mm-hmm uh and they got
like right into it it was nice no
[ __ ] around yeah that's good yeah
well i i feel like the first season it
did take a lot of time to get going i
felt like it was just like the first
half of
the first half of demon slayer season
one
it's uh was i mean it was just very
standard shown and stuff you know it was
like it was nice it was like comfort
food you know you knew what you were
getting and i it was only until like the
[ __ ] spider arc where i feel like it
actually got yeah it kicked off really
really good i don't know i feel like
this season so far i've i'm on episode
seven
uh yeah really impressed with it so far
i've not a single episode i thought was
boring pacing's really good animation is
just god tier well i must say like one
aspect of demon slayer that i've just
like never really understood it's like i
don't it's it's a good show right yeah
but do you think it deserves as much of
like an insane hype in japan as it does
i mean what i mean in japan it's
worldwide no no but like i feel in japan
it's on another it's hard to explain if
you don't live here like how insane the
hype for comments like everyone knows
kimensu is [ __ ] popular everywhere
yeah everyone's watching the new season
everyone went to go see the new movie
but like yeah in japan it's when i say
some when something is inescapable
that i feel kimitsu in japan perfectly
suits that word because everywhere you
look yeah some product or some store or
something is doing something with
kimetsu yeah even like five-year-olds to
like 80 old dude like my entire japanese
side of the family has like a favorite
like a top three characters like demon
slayer it's like it's so weird that it's
so weird that like i so like i have like
a like a four-year-old cousin right who
obviously loves demon slayer right
because [ __ ] every kid loves them
so like for for christmas i was like
breathing yeah
so for christmas i was like oh i'm gonna
get him something demon slayer related
right so i asked his mom my cousin just
being like
uh what what is uh what is his favorite
character right and she just lists off
like two or three characters i was like
all right cool easy and then she was
like oh by the way i like this character
uh my your uncle likes this character
likes this character and i'm like what
imagine imagine my 60 something year old
uncle being like yeah i [ __ ] love
shinobu dude like she's like my [ __ ]
favorite character i'm like that's so
weird it's so weird
in japan literally everyone
of every age generation is watching
demonstrations or has watched it it's
intense yeah do you think it's the movie
that's got got it this big because i
didn't realize how big it was it was not
like no i think it was already i think
how big it already is was the reason why
the movie is like the [ __ ] like
highest grossing anime because because
like it was like that one year away beat
out one piece by manga sales but like
tenfold or something it was yeah
before like it was like the years before
that the top selling mong was like one
piece one piece one piece one piece one
piece by like a long shot yeah and then
demon slayer came out and it was just
like yeah let me like ten times like
you're it was still hilarious when you
saw the graph because it was like all
these other shonen jump stuff and then
it's like one piece it's like demon
slayer
because within 2019 the the rankings for
like weekly rankings were given like the
other the manga rankings like
demonstrate was like everything yeah it
was
yeah because i was going to say
jiu-jitsu guys and seems almost equally
as inescapable recently because of the
new movie yeah yeah because of the new
movie but like even before that like
after we got released it just it just
seemed like it just had such a big
explosion
and i'm not sure like
i i haven't been living in japan long
enough to see like how big or how fast
trends come and go but like it it was
way bigger than i thought it was going
to be yeah i mean like you know in japan
trends come and go so quickly because i
feel once something trends in japan yeah
japan just milks the absolute [ __ ] out
of it like you know
throwback if you can remember ppap for
instance
back in the [ __ ] day right
for you kids that's pen pineapple apple
pen
uh when that was [ __ ] big like three
or four years ago how long it was longer
than that i think it was longer than
that right like that was [ __ ]
everywhere yeah in japan
and it's crazy like when you go to the
supermarket they play it yeah right like
it still has staying power but like
i don't know
i don't know what it is about demon
slayers specifically when it comes to
like a a trending anime in japan because
every i feel there's always
that one series that is trending ever in
japan right like during the different
periods like it's it's nothing new to
demon slayer i feel in japan yeah but i
was like what is it about demon slayer
specifically
that it's literally appealing to
every single generation i don't know i
don't get it it's a good show you have
like the family-friendly appeal right
yeah
like i can't imagine a four-year-old
watching these demons like heads getting
cut off right being like that's not the
same as like beauty and the beast yeah
right it's not like a disney ip or you
know like a pixar ip or anything like
that right where it can appeal to the
family like even comparing it to like
other anime or other shonen it's just
it's it's good it's it's good it's a
good show every time i make this
argument people just think oh you're
just a demon slayer like hater i'm like
i'm not i enjoy the show but i just
don't understand what about this show
specifically that is
literally inescapable i don't even think
it's like my top three shonen oh it's
definitely not in my time
it's not the animation is just so good
it makes it so easy to watch right oh
this is just amazing
but the thing is it's not only because
of the anime though but because you know
like the mongols
as well right so it's something like
fundamental about demon slayer that is
somehow appealing to everyone
and i don't get it and yet the run time
of the manga was so short someone needs
to write a [ __ ] dissertation on this
man like
it is genuinely
interesting because i i like as good as
demon slayer is i don't know how unique
it is it's it's it's not right it's not
exceedingly unique in any one aspect at
all and it's not like one piece that's
been around for you know 100 volumes
right like i think demonstration only
has like 23 24 volumes or something
which for a shonen jump manga is really
short
yeah are there just this many mouth
breathers in the world
it's like just like maybe just it's
the total concentration technique is
breathing through your nose
take that ball gag out
my nose has been blocked for like two
weeks i've just i've been a mouth
breathing for two weeks that's why i
watched it
finally i can relate
to this anime
what is even like the top character in
demon slayer in terms of like popularity
in terms of popularity yeah it's got to
be tangier right is it tangier it's it's
no it's not
no it's no it's not okay there's
actually i can see there is a lot of
zenith why it's like we it depends
because
i think the the top five definitely is
like tanjiro nezugo uh zanetsu you know
scare and shinobu as like the top five
but like hardcore fans and there's a lot
of hardcore fans of japan all love all
of the hushers yeah the hashtags are
pretty cool yeah
that's you know like i don't know if
that's like their way of being like yeah
i'm a true fan because like with some
shows you immediately you immediately
know what the most popular character is
going to be like yeah
it's easily going to be gojo yeah
everybody's like every that's that's
that character was built to be the most
popular yeah exactly right
but like
in in deemed slay you just don't know
who's gonna like i can't think who is
gonna be and if it's zenitsu then i've
lost faith in yanzee
i'm glad i'm not the only one who can't
[ __ ] stand say anything
so much cooler though yeah right i need
to i [ __ ] hate it
i don't i don't understand zany two fans
i don't i don't know it's i mean it's
like i said it's it's it's a good show
this is relatable
are you relatable
[ __ ]
they wish they had some power that could
make them useful
i'm jeremy
i know why the cast is popular because
you can call every character cinnamon
bun that's uh
why why can't you do that
[Laughter]
i don't know okay i'm trying i'm trying
to like understand this myself i don't
know it's such an interesting like like
social study just because like you know
because we've seen anime [ __ ] your your
entp type whatever the [ __ ] it is tell
me your favorite your favorite hashera
that's how i know that's how i know if
you're a real deal [ __ ] your star sign
yeah yeah you're zodiac cringe bro tell
me your favorite hashtag and why update
that match.com yeah for that moment
because before demonstrate was like the
biggest like kind of cultural trend in
terms of anime has has there been like
an anime i'm sure there must be have
been like other animes that i don't know
yeah or in terms of like call the
japanese public as much as demonstrator
is doing well slam dunk back in the day
was definitely like around there mainly
yeah was like like slam dunk was so big
it became a cultural phenomenon are you
actually in japan or like the world i'm
asking in japan i don't think in the
world there has been one yet no not
really no you're not yet patreon was for
a little bit while it was out i don't
know
i look at one punch man and i'm just
like it was a big deal when it came out
it was a big deal but i i see attack on
titan season four being a bigger deal
let's just have more time to brew yeah
this had more time to like like relish
but but even then comparing like attack
on titan season four to some like other
mainstream stuff it's not there yet it
had hype but it didn't really create
like a cultural like shift yeah or
anything whereas like sometimes you see
in japan they there is a show
that comes along that does create a
cultural shift like slam dunk
uh back in the day um my hero maybe i
don't think my hero i don't know i hear
it's really big here it is really big it
is really like i i feel like the mic
was just a million times bigger i feel
like mother my hero hype train
like we thought the my hero hype train
was big and then demon slayer came out
and even though i think they're like in
terms of show quality they're around
about the same you know
when we're all getting into this corner
we are not getting into this connor i'm
just saying wait wait which side are you
on i think this slayer is much better
than mine okay i agree with that i agree
how are you comparing them [ __ ] off
okay in the grand scheme of things i
think that they're of like comparable
level of quality in terms of like if if
someone wants to say looking forward to
the summer
what i'm trying to say if if someone
wants to say that they prefer my hero
academia over demon slayer i'm not gonna
lose my [ __ ] unlike a lot of people in
the community
look everyone's telling me that my
hero's gonna come back and see season
six with the my villains academia arc
which i've heard it's amazing it might
be amazing it's shonen like black clover
fans have been saying for years it's
just because and
it's literally it hasn't escaped out of
the monument which is because like we
all know this so i don't know what
happened with my hair around season
three it just became like a snore fest i
didn't even get to that point i i can't
believe i did i watched like season
three and i was like bored out my mind
watching it i was like this is so boring
just do something
have something happen
be heroes
leave school or something for [ __ ]
sage that's why hunter hunter was good
because they [ __ ] moved they actually
did something they like got on with the
[ __ ] store until they did it until
until he stopped riding it that's why
the story stopped not because he just
kept going in like it was like in
purgatory at this [ __ ] school yeah as
as an anime only uh as an anime only
what i think what drew me to by the way
yeah as what drew me out of like what
made me lose a lot of hybrid between
uh in my hero was
you know the first few arcs would
concentrate on the school kids doing
their thing i'm like cool you're getting
to see progression and then they started
introducing the wider world of the
heroes and like these bigger the these
like vast plots that like pertain to the
entire world and you're like cool this
is amazing this is interesting
let's go back to high school afterwards
i'm just like what how can you do this
to me like
let's go to let's go to a concert arc
that i don't give a [ __ ] about where you
just introduce like the entire villains
world and i'm just like
and yeah
it feels like it feels torn because
you're like just leave the safety net
you know just leave it like
you clearly have built this world that's
interesting i think everyone likes the
world just just just let them get out of
school
come on come on actually expandable get
on get on with it yeah actually do it
but i get it it's it's safe you can milk
it you can get 10 more years out of it
stay in the [ __ ] school never leave
this one isn't it isn't the manga ending
soon yeah the manga is ending soon this
year right
did they eventually get out of school is
that to read the manga [ __ ]
well i'm never going to finish it
because i'm i've lost all interest in
the anime because i was like i i can't
wait for these clips to get like [ __ ]
clipped and put on twitter out of
context
like i can't i can't wait for shown and
twitter to get on our asses
they're my hero fans what are they going
to do ask their mum for more fortnite or
robux like [ __ ] off
what
mama
cancel
come on it fell off it fell off man it
did it did l ratio no one talks about it
no one talks about that i think that's
the biggest thing is that i don't even
think it's bad i just think it just it
got boring it just got boring but yeah i
i i didn't hate it but like no one talks
about it now i feel like there's no
point watching it because who am i going
to talk to her about no one watches it